Путіну йому приписують якісь дуже
неймовірні якості дуже обмежена дуже
обмежена людина
ви бачили як ставляться на північний
абсолютно жоден американський такий
були ставлення до нас
Росія має бути обов'язково
позбавлена ядерної зброї
І взагалі Ну розумієте тобто Росія має
бути поставлена на певною міри на коліна
[музика]
сьогодні говоримо із українським
політиком і дипломатом першим послом
України в Росії Володимиром
крижанівським рада вітати вас Доброго
дня пане Володимире ви були Одним із
перших хто формував дипломатичні
відносини між Україною та Росією тоді на
початку 90-х наскільки були відчутні
загарбницькі апетити Росії для вас я вам
зразу розповім щоб ви розуміли 2 грудня
результати референного стали відомі
91-го року я в Москві в посольстві
прийшла одна єдина людина Галя
Старовойтова і потім убили
ну така дисидентка трошки
вона прийшла принесла три гвоздички як
начебто комуніст
поздоровила не передбачаю розповідати
вона каже ви знаєте в конце октября
я можу українською в кінці жовтня
прийшла до Борис Миколайовича і сказали
Борис Николай а не уйдут
и буду сказано с таким жахом дисидент
інтелігент І оце що Україна відірветься
від маминої спідниці жах
Галя
нам главное выбросить мечем и с Кремля а
потом мы их скрутим
розумієте
Борис Николаевич
что Вы ещё не сделали для Украины Ну я
би сказав якою вище ідоти не зробили
став не до України Тобто це Розумієте це
оце абсолютно нормально а потом скрутим
оце нормально
ненормально Ну нормально виглядає
поведінка одиниць
це одиниці в Росії які розуміли Україну
а там взагалі вони нас не розуміли в
одному з інтерв'ю за місяць до
повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в
Україну вам поставили питання чи буде
війна і ви відповіли мовляв гадаєте що в
Росії є хоча б якісь залишки розуму
Тобто ви до останнього сподівалися що
Росія не нападе на Україну Я не міг
повірити що можна до такої міри
збожевуліти
розумієте
адекватна людина не може робити того що
робить Росія
адекватна країна еліта тому зрозуміло
чекав що десь у них вистачить розума Але
після 14-го року я тільки чекав коли
вони ще серйозніші тому для мене не було
це дві ноги те що вони зробили оце
скрутят от Я чекав коли ж вони почнуть
Чому він Спитаєте чому тоді не скрутили
А ви знаєте не було потуги
барель нафти коштує 10-12 доларів
собівартість
5-6 доларів тобто на одному березі вони
заробляли 5 доларів 6 це дуже мало Росія
стояла взагалі в 91-му році на грані
голоду Це було жахливо Ви не уявляєте в
Україні нічого подібне не було Це був
жах ірисейському магазині було 3-4 сорти
ковбаси
жахливі видовище в магазині були шаром
поки в Москву не їхали знамениті
ковбасний рік тому що не будеш купувати
і тому вони не мали у них не було
можливості о послухайте Єльцин це це
зовсім інше фігура це ж не босяк це не
Шпана не
розумієте ну Путін порівнює з єльциним
це сявка як говорять таких блатних
кругах петроградської сторони
були фігура і зрозуміло він би якби міг
він би набагато раніше пішов Сьогодні ми
з вами спілкуємося як із політиком як із
дипломатом але За освітою ви інженер і
не один рік попрацювали за професією Як
так сталося що ви опинилися в політиці і
як стали дипломатом Це дуже смішно
ви розумієте десь 28 серпня 91-го року
мені телефонують як кажуть вони будуть
прийдіть на засідання Президії Верховної
Ради А що таке ми не знаємо це
сказали що покличник крижанівського
приходжу сюди на третій поверх в
Верховній Раді а тоді країни управляв не
президент президента не було країни
оформляла Президії Верховної Ради
прийшов
ви розумієте щойно були переговори з
росіянами вони приїжджали сюди Ми рішили
встановити
з Росією
Я так думаю про себе як діти стосунки
наша ніхто не визнав не в стосунки Ну
добре так кажу так що Ну от думали
думали і вирішили вас направити туди
надзвичайно і повноваженим представником
Дякую на це дивитись і кажу взагалі без
захвату Ну бо я Росію добре здала
Ну а все ж таки я кажу можна я подумати
ну недовго
ну скільки ну хвилин 15 Ну давайте тоді
я зразу скажу Я погоджуюсь
але я Потім вирішив знати А чому ж ми
Я питаю у ініціатора яке потім узнав
цього питання
фантастично
такої людини з величезним почуттям
гумору і дуже цікаво дуже небесне але
дивлюсь філенко
Я кажу Володя А чому на мені зупинились
були це взагалі з моєї подачі
ви в гарних стосунках були всіма
комуняками Ми вирішили можемо із
росіянами ви будете в нормальних
стосунках Боже як Володя помилився
з комуністами можна домовитися з
українськими
з росіянами не можна
Він помилився Я теж помилявся Я все-таки
думав Розумієте я був більшою частиною
мав стосунки з таким інженерними колами
Ну як розрахувати як побудувати
щось А тут а тут з іншим хоча навіть у
них часто-густо сиділи імперських начало
сиділа знаючи Росія з середини Чому ви
погодилися там Працювати Чому ви
погодилися там жити
серед інтер'єнції тоді побудувала така
такий слоган як зараз кажуть якщо не ми
то хто
навпаки Я добре знав Росії
я добре знаю між іншим Моя дружина
росіянка петербурзька я розумів що в
принципі як простий дипломат якби
простий дипломат туди поїхав навіть дуже
досвідчений трошки перегравала бо ти
менше розумієте у народного депутата
було більше можливостей я міг краще Ну я
це було добре що я був нардепом і це
завдяки цьому і потім дійсно я знав
Росію Добре Ну можу сказати я за
67-го десь по
90-ий рік
За 24 роки роботи
я ну разів 150 був відряджені в Росії
можете собі уявити я прекрасно знала
які вони росіяни і які вони
тому я на це не важився
А скільки років свого життя Ви прожили в
Росії і скільки прожили там як посол
України
під час війни два роки
буряті два роки
три роки
послом сім і оцими наїздами і ще років Я
думаю років 9 і проживлюсь
пане Володимире ви як посол були
присутні на історичних перемовинах між
Україною та Росією зокрема ви були
учасником обговорення щодо долі
чорноморського флоту І от у своїй книжці
ми знову здобули державність ви пишете
про те що тоді на українську делегацію
Росія цитую почала неймовірно тиснути
про якийсь саме тиск йдеться тиск був
завжди абсолютно У них абсолютно
однаковий був підхід до наших до наших
керівників приїжджає Леонід Данилович в
перший раз як Прем'єр 92-й рік
їде в Кремль Я кажу поїхати з вами
Володя Я хочу сам на сам подивитись
приїжджають через дві години злий як 100
чортів
ні нічого вони що зовсім дзвонили я що
їм Я був директором самого великого
заводу військовий заводу в Україні
вони з якого вони приймають я хто Їм
Вони розумієте ви завжди як тільки
приїжджав новий керівник з якими справа
вони першими
спершу намагалися зробити фейсом обтейну
там там максимально жорстко
подивитися стримаю удар не тримаю
практично я не пам'ятаю що ми з кимось
цього не робив перша атака завжди була
навальна
безпардонна причому такого максимум
обов'язково
і ви знаєте Практично всі
ставали українськими націоналістами вони
практично завжди досягали зворотний
ефекту
це налаштована проти це призводило до
дискомфорту в стосунках
ну розумієте коли ти починаєш коли ти
починаєш що на тебе тиснуть давлять
примушують
розумієте починаєш думати і ти починаєш
шукати
тих хто на тебе не буде тиснути
це
Ну потім розумієте ну я хочу сказати
є такі російські слово мілкотревчати ну
керівник ВВП
ну розумієте Путіну йому приписують
якісь дуже неймовірні якості дуже
обмежена дуже обмежена людина яку робить
таку мерзоту таку гидоту таку такий жах
по відношенню до своєї країни це людина
не варта взагалі там нема про що
говорити він шкодить в першу чергу не в
Україні в першу чергу він зробить зло
для своєї країни це для Росії
розуміти От і все До речі дипломатична
кар'єра вас познайомила з Володимиром
Путіним особисто Розкажіть будь ласка
коли і за яких умов відбулася ваша
зустріч з нинішнім президентом Росії з
Путіним та були 40 років 50 років
прориву блокади
Це був 94-й рік
і Собчак запросив всіх
країн які приймали участь
Азербайджан акул німці американці
англійці і французи і ми були
і він сказав що опікати
посла України Німеччини буде мій
заступник Господин Путін вийшли такими
решами
з малим количеством
ви знаєте що дуже цікаво такому
світло-сірому костюмі в лютому місяці
дуже дивно І от з такими рукавами
хлопці викупили купили цей костюм на
початку 9 класу щоб він вистачило до
нової розумієте враження було таке
нічого і не говорив таку абсолютно сидів
між нові дружини і тут же посол
Німеччини 4,5 години нічого такого але
єдине що весь час
зірках
Я підійшов до
теж заступника першого заступника
Савчука Сергія Біляєва кажу Сергій штон
так
рискает
он говорит он
фейсбешник
ну тобто це звідти
нічого нема Боже що ну не розумієте що
керівник держави може бути тільки ідіота
якщо загинула підводний човен загинуло
100 з чимось людей Екіпаж треба мати
сувору трагічну зміну мало не плакати
щоб зараз потечуть сльози А він каже
водка
про що ми говоримо про Який інтелект про
який рівень
також від початку вторгнення Росії в
Україну Володимир Путін і його
публічники неодноразово вдавалися до
ядерного шантажу на тлі цього в Україні
почалися розмови про Будапештський
меморандум і його доречність взагалі Ну
там приміром давита архамія заявив про
те що
роззброєння ядерне роззброєння України
це Фатальна помилка Кравчука я наскільки
знаю ви думки протилежної Я вважаю що
треба було віддати
ну приїжджає новий посол пікінг
і ну в першу чергу когда вы де діти
шпу
шахтний
ракет
все так як зараз ставляться до Північної
Кореї Ми бачили як ставляться на
північний
жоден Америка там нема вони прекрасно
все розуміли вони боялися одного у них
не було добрих даних про те що вони
працювали раніше з Москвою вони бачили
голову в Москві який був периферійний на
периферійні увазі і тому Київ
Вони не знали що чекати тут і раптом ці
скупляться бомбу і почнуть в неї гасати
те що вони зараз роблять по відношенню
поставлені до Північної Кореї отаки були
вставлені до нас
категорично ні І тільки віднесе все але
ставлення було не таке як у них як у
росіян коли ми віддали ракети середній І
ближньої
отут
військовому Порту на кораблі сидить
перший заступник Міністра Тарасюк і
заступник російського міністра
закордонского бердянником і Тарасюк каже
послухайте ми вам віддали нові Ну за це
ж ми маємо
запам'ятайте
підсудстві Росії України в Росії
відбулись остаточний перебування
договору про те що ми віддаємо ракети
данної дії
там по черзі було
американського посольстві Міністерство
закордонних справ на останнє перебування
все після цього
не післязавтра приїжджає
я бачу поїхав росіянин росіяни поїхали
американці і їдуть Я не можу зрозуміти а
переговори вони
не посли а радники Посланники Я питаю що
таке спитай кажу Я питаю у радники
посланника американського таких Джиммі
Коллінз він потім став Джеймс холлінз
він став потім по селом а потім був
навіть був заступником держсекретаря А
чому ми Чому ви сидите росіяни ж поїхали
після Другої світової війни Ми зрозуміли
з радянськими дипломатами не можна
просто так вони в останній момент
візьмуть поставлять Комуни та
Казнить нельзя помиловать і буде скандал
тому ми відчитуємо кожну літеру на вашу
думку яка основна відмінність між
українцями та росіянами в головне
в чому відрізняються У них є цар батюшка
вони от цар хороший бо я не поганий
тобто вони
звикли до патерному їх Ви привчили до
цього
в чому ж я сказав
українці вчора обрали гетьмана а через
три дні вони з його посади чомусь
пам'ятаю тільки перших чотири літери
геть
от в цьому тому що ми ми європейці Ну
трошки
занадто європейці Це не гріх нашої
поляків
поляків теж це є розумієте польські
що один посол на Сейм міг сказати
парламент щодо закону не позвоно все і
закон був провалений Чим це все
закінчилось трьома розподілом Польщі але
все-таки дуже добре що в нас є
Жага до волі до свободи
розумієте
чим російським піралізм відрізняється
від імпералізмів інших
Практично всі імперії були побудовані
метрополія в Європі А колонії
Там за горизонтом
а Російська імперія формувалася
по-іншому
приєднання
і ці території
треба було тримати
вони розуміли що
ці імперії послати туди 500 тисяч
війська
17-му чи 18 сторіччі неможливо
тому вони якось розуміли що треба цих
туземців все-таки якось щось таке а ці
не розуміли цей розуміли що що треба
військо війська війська більше
Росію правлять 100 тисяч чиновників
казав Микола I
треба було вони розумієте в чому
головний недолік і відмінність
Російської імперії вона розвивалася на
відміну від всіх європейських країн
екстенсивно
ширика страна моя
лісов полеглих цього року зарадим цю
річку а потім
цю річку а потім загарбаємо ту річку і
її зарадив так дійдемо до Тихого океану
може за цей час та перша річка вже стане
як Темза світлою
А як ви гадаєте за яких умов Україна та
Росія зможуть співіснувати Як сусіди
перше Вони мають програти відео
другий світ висвіт товариства нарешті
повинно зрозуміти
що завжди з цієї країни
випав зі зло
і тому треба зробити так щоб викорінити
саме
начала цього зла тобто Росія має бути
обов'язково
позбавлена ядерної зброї
І взагалі Ну розумієте тобто Росія має
бути поставлена на певної міри на коліна
чи вірите ви в те що Росія розпадеться
ну певне будуть буде певне ну розумієте
там настільки
Вони ж все-таки чому нам зараз між іншим
дуже тяжко тому що вона вже був єдиний
господарчий комплекс А там ще сильніше
і тому дуже тяжко розуму все-таки думає
вистачить про те щоб якісь на певних
якихось правилах триматися китайці між
іншим не думають захоплюватись
А за чим красотку користь якщо її можна
так говорити Тобто можна поступово
тримати Росію під своїм впливом
пане Володимире Напевно ви як і я цього
місяця неодноразово прокидалися від
звуків вибухівно чи як ви загалом
переживаєте війну
жахливо жахливо розумієте ну що
ми не є дружина Вона росіянка
В неї були мама у неї були сестра
Ми не можемо приїхати на їхні могили
розумієте
Я не думаю ми не практично нема людей в
Росії з ким мені хотілось би
спілкуватися Тобто ми не бачимо потреби
колись Моя дружина сказала сину ми
повези дівчат
Петербург нехай подивлюся
Мама я два тижні маю слухати виключно
російську мову не хочу
не хочу не хочу
нічого хорошого там не буде ма
для чого ви були одним із тих нардепів
що голосували за Акт проголошення
незалежності України і от у своїй книзі
ви так з теплом згадуєте 24 серпня 1991
року і такими словами що це був день
який буває раз в житті а якими словами
ви можете описати 24 лютого 2022 року
жахливо просто
розумієте
почуття
омерзіння до всіх них
ми знаємо що там не один Путін вони всі
ну розумієте ну Моя дружина мого
племінника двоюрідна вона мені каже Ну
почему вона скрадёт нефть
мене не розуміють що вкрасти газ Ми не
можемо тому що на виходив ми маємо
віддати газ в Європу і я думаю жахом Оце
оце оця ідота полізе полізете Я єдиний
про що жалію що я не можу воювати
Я прийшов тебе в оборону
вони подивилися
швидко допомогу і у вас відвезуть
павловську
від вас скільки каже шкода
А толку від вас ніяк 82 роки
я про це жалію
жалко Якби я мав таку змогу як молоді
у нього попереду життя і уб'ють а вони
показують позаду життя якщо ми не уб'ють
не так страшно А молодого Він тільки
піднімається тільки хоче бачити світ і
це оця російська мерзота вкорочує міг
вона йому каже Ти не повинен жити
чому я на моїй землі
чому
німці це зрозуміли
Ну тому що німці
великий народ який
одурили А цей Народ ходить 800 років
одурений
і ні в одному випадку
А як ви гадаєте чи коли-небудь
відкриється у росіян очі
якщо ми виграємо цю війну і якщо
підвис під товариство поставить
певні умови і якщо ми вступимо НАТО може
якщо Україна буде в НАТО
та молився щоб Україна була в нас вони
не можуть
пане Володимире Дякую вам за цю розмову